any hot sauce that you come across
you're gonna find a red version and
you're gonna find a green version
sriracha being such a hugely popular
sauce kind of never made sense where
there was only one style my name is
gideon stirrup and i make green sriracha
i first came across green sriracha when
I was in Asia about six years ago I had
heard about this seemed like a mythical
thing but I've seen an actual picture of
it I was kind of obsessed with it so I
would go to all these markets and I
would say do you carry green sriracha
most people look at me like we don't
know what you're talking about
there was a guy in Osaka he's like no no
we don't have that but we kind of make
something similar on our own so he kind
of explained to me what he did I tweaked
it a little bit to kind of make it my
own and that's kind of how the recipe
started
people think sriracha is the name of a
company because one company dominates
the entire market everyone knows the
rooster sauce but sriracha is just the
name of a sauce
similar to ketchup or mayonnaise I
decided to make my sriracha with a green
chilli because I wanted it to be more
fresh tasting and have a little bit more
of a kick that's essentially what the
green Chili's achieved these are ground
up green serrano chiles from Peru and
from Mexico and here we have the garlic
that goes in with the sauce everything
is gonna be combined in the mixers
the results will be a smooth clean hot
sauce our product went on sale April 1st
no one knew who we were we only had like
15,000 units and I thought this 15,000
units was going to last about two weeks
into it we had major media outlets
contacting us writing articles people
were kind of going crazy we at one point
we're the number one selling hot sauce
on Amazon after about 10 days we sold
out now we're making about 70,000 units
we're aiming to produce 50 to 100,000
units a month moving forward we're
trying to have it available at
supermarkets everywhere I hope to sell
millions of these a year
I'm not doing this because it's my
passion necessarily I'm doing it because
I think there's a lot of money to be
made
I don't think big opportunities come
along many times in life and I think if
you're confronted with one it's an
irresponsible move not to act on it when
you have the chance